[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام لما كنا صغار
كنا نشاهد توم اند جيري ولما صرنا كبار
صرنا نشاهد لافروف اند
كيري اليست الاعيب وزيري خارجيه روسيا
وامريكا في سوريا اشبه بافلام الكرتون قال
شو قال مختلفين حول الوضع السوري اليس
الروس والامريكيون والاسرائيليون على قلب
رجل واحد في سوريا اليست مناوشات
الاعلاميه لذر الرماد في العيون والضحك
على الذقون ريثما تحسم روسيا الوضع في
سوريا وحلب تحديدا
كيف نصدق ان الروس والامريكيين يتصارعون
على سوريا اذا كانت روسيا واسرائيل سمنا
على عسل في سوريا ما قيمه الاحتجاجات
الامريكيه على التصريحات الروسيه في سوريا
اذا كان الاسرائيليون والروس ينامون في
فراش واحد في
سوريا لكن في المقابل اليس من السذاجه
تقزيم الصراع الروسي الامريكي الى افلام
كرتونيه في سوريا الا تدل التصريحات
الروسيه والامريكيه والاوروبيه ان الحرب
البارده اذا عادت بقوه وان الروس باتوا
يتحدون الامريكيين جديا في سوريا وغيرها
اليس من الخطا القول ان روسيا تدخلت في
سوريا بضوء اخضر امريكي الا تعكس
التصريحات الروسيه الناريه تحديا حقيقيا
لامريكا الم يحذر وزير الخارجيه الالماني
من ان الثقه باتت معدومه بين الشرق والغرب
الا يدخل التمدد الروسي في الشرق الاوسط
وغيره في اطار المشروع الروسي الاكبر
المعروف بوراسيا الجديده اسئله اطرحها على
الدكتور رياض عيد الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه والعلاقات الدوليه وعلى
السيد ايمن العاسمي عضو المجلس العسكري في
الجيش السوري الحر نبدا نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام
نحن معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاك سيد
العاسمي لو بدات معك
لدينا
تصويت على تويتر ليس على اي موقع اخر بل
على موقع عالمي لا يستطيع احد ان يتدخل
فيه والجميع يصوت من كل انحاء العالم بكل
حريه حسب
ارائهم السؤال يقول هل امريكا وروسيا في
سوريا
حلفاء ام
اعداء
85 بال يقولون الروس والامريكيون حلفاء في
سوريا 15 بال يقولون فقط اعداء ماذا تقرا
في هذه النتيجه يعني ما الذي يجعل هذه
الشريحه الكبيره من الشارع العربي وليس
السوري تعتقد ان ما يحدث من مناوشات بين
الامريكيين والروس في سوريا هي عباره عن
ذر للرماد في العيون والضحك على الذقون
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي لك
وللدكتور رياض والمشاهدين جميعا سيدي
حقيقه هذه النتيجه تثبت ان هناك وعي
يتزايد في الشارع العربي وفي الشارع عموما
ان السياسه لم تعد تستطيع خداع الشعوب
اكثر من السابق في السابق كان هناك مجال
كبير للخداع نعم الان هناك يعني صحوه
وايضا هذا الامر يثبت ان هناك مراقبه
للمجريات التي تجري في سوريا يعني حقيقه
عندما نرجع الى الموقف المصري امس انا
سابدا من اخر موقف يثبت ان هناك حلفاء
داخل المنطقه العربيه للامريكان صوتوا
لصالح الروس او يقفون الى جانب الروس
الموقف المصري وقاله السيد وزير مندوب
مندوب مندوب المعلم المدوب السعودي في
مجلس الامن قال ان الموقف المصري كان
خارج النطاق العربي وكان السنغال اقرب من
المؤسف ان السنغال وماليزيا كانت اقرب
للموقف العربي من الموقف الم هذا دليل هل
دكتور فيصل هل تعتقد ان مصر تستطيع ان
تصوت لصالح هذا القرار لولا الرغبه
الامريكيه كلنا نعرف تماما ان المصريين
تحديدا والجيش المصري 40 الى 60% من
امكانيه امكانياته وميزانيته تاتي من
امريكا هذه نقطه النقطه الاخرى ايضا يعني
المصريون لا يتجرون ان ياخذوا مثل هذه
الخطوه لولا ضوء اخضر امريكي واسرائيلي يا
سيدي ليس المصريين ايضا هذا الامر يعني
مفروغ منه هناك امر اخر اريد ان اقوله
بصراحه وربما يحجب او يحجم كثير من الناس
عن عن ذكره حقيقه هو الموقف الاردني طبعا
الاردنيون وقوفهم جيد من الثوره السوريه
لكن حقيقه عندما تشاهد ان التنسيق في
الجنوب في غرفه عمليات واحده مع الروس
وهذا الامر معلن وليس خفي عندما تنسق
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه مع الروس
والمملكه تاريخيا هي حليف امريكي الحقيقه
وايضا لها علاقات قويه مع اسرائيل
واتفاقيه سلام وادي عرب وكلنا نعرف هذه
الاتفاقيه ايضا هناك تنسيق اخر للملكه
الاردنيه مع الجانب الامريكي داخل العراق
الان شيوخ الانبار في في الاردن يقومون
بتشكيل هيئه سياسيه او ما يشبه المعارضه
ويقوم الاردن الاخ الاردنيون في ايضا
التفاهم مع الروس بما يخص الجنوب ونتج عنه
تهدئه الجنوب باختصار بس باختصار يعني كي
نجمع الموضوع لانه كل هذه المؤشرات تعطينا
انطباعا بان الصراع او ما يسمى بالصراع
الروسي الامريكي في سوريا والمنطقه ضحك
على الذقون كذب يا سيدي اريد ان يعني تو
ان جري صرنا نشوف لافروف اند كاري المقدمه
حقيقه التي تقدمت فيها حضرتك كانت تشرح
الموقف تماما يعني ما قلته حقيقه لكن الان
هو كرت بطعم الدماء وبرائحه الدماء يعني
تصور ان تقوم دوله مثل روسيا تدمر حلب وت
وتقصف المشافي وتقتل كل هذا هؤلاء البشر
وتنظر امريكا وتقول وكانها تتكلم بلسان
جمعيه خيريه عندما تكلم في الامس المندوب
البريطاني قال اننا لن لن لن اشكرك ل
تشوركين المندوب الروسي يعني هذه لغه
حقيقه سخيفه وساذج عندما يقول مندوب دوله
بريطانيا هذه هذا الاسلوب الى الى الى
المندوب الروسي اختصار بجمله واحده اذا
يعني الكلام عن صراع لولا انه متوافقون
لما استطاعت الدول الحليفه داخل المنطقه
العربيه بالتصرف مع الروس دون ان يحاسبه
احد لان في الحقيقه هي تتبع لهذا الحلف
وتدور في فلكه الحلف الامريكي عندما تدور
في حلف الروسي فاعلم تماما ان الروس ايضا
هم كوكب اخر يدور في هذا الفلك الامريكي
جميل جدا دكتور رياض سمعت هذا الكلام يعني
اي انتم في معسكر الممانعه والمقاومه منذ
سنوات وسنوات تقولون لنا انه هناك صراع
امريكي روسي على سوريا لنقل سوريا من محور
الممانعه الى المحور الغربي بينما الان
نجد انه هذا هذا الكلام غير موجود على ارض
الواقع لان الامريكان والروس
والاسرائيليين ينامون في فراش واحد فاذا
سوريا اصلا هي موجوده في في المحور الغربي
الصهيوني الامبريالي وكل كلامكم عن ممانعه
وكذا ضحك على الذقون كمان كيف ترد
اولا انا لست مع التوصيف يلي حكيته انت
بالعكس انا لي توصيف مناقض
له وهذا التوصيف يرتكز على حقيقه الصراع
الكوني الذي يحدث بين العمالقه وتحديدا
بين روسيا الاتحاديه والحلف
الذي يدعم روسيا الاتحاديه اعني به
شانغهاي منظمه شانغهاي للتعاون وصولا الى
الصين والبريكس الصراع حاليا في العالم
يقوم بين قوى صاعده على راس الصين وروسيا
وقوى مهيمنه على راس امريكا بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي حاولت ان تبقي الهيمنه
على الكون بنظام احادي
القطبيه سوريا هي احد ساحات الصراع ب بين
ه النظامين نظام الاحادي القطبيه بزعامه
امريكا التي ترفض ان تسلم ان هذا النظام
سقط الى غير رجعه وهناك نظام متعدد
الاقطاب يسير نحو البزوغ وبالتالي هذا
النظام تقوم به روسيا والصين وحلفائهما
بؤر الصراع في هذا النظام بدات في جورجيا
ثم انتقلت الى سوريا ثم انتقلت الى
اوكرانيا وحاليا ستفجر الوضع في وسط اسيا
انا ما اراه ان سوريا هي احد حلقات الصراع
في هذا الصراع الكوني بين العملاقين بين
العمالقه بين العمالقه والشعب السوري
والناس تدفع هذا هذا الثمن لان المعركه
تدور في سوريا وعليها سوريا هي المصهر
التي ت الذي تدور فيه هذه الصراعات
الكونيه انا لا ارى اطلاقا ان ال التنسيق
بين السوري والروسي قائم ودليلي على ذلك
حين دخلت روسيا حين دخلت التنسيق ما بين
الروسي والامريكي ايه تنسيق في العناوين
لكن في الجوهر صراع خفي وقائم بشكل غير
عادي كيف عناوين دكتور يعني ممكن خليني بس
وضح شغله تفضل اولا حين دخلت روسيا
المعركه في سوريا دخلته في 30/9 20105 حين
كانت
جلسه المجل الامم المتحده وكان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين يريد ان يلقي خطابه في
الذكرى 60 للامم المتحده اذكر وبالتالي
دخل الى سوريا في هذا
الموضوع بس بس دكتور بس مشان ما تروح
النقطه هذه في هذا الوقت بالذات التقى
بوتن في الامم المتحده ب باوباما بالرئيس
الامريكي وبعد يومين دخل سوريا بضوء اخضر
امريكي يعني كانت اجت مباشره بعد اللقاء
مع الامريكان فاذا لا تقول لي صراع لا
اسمحلي حين دخل دخل الروسي اراد الروسي ان
يدخل لكي يعطي ايقا جديدا ويوجه رسائل الى
امريكا والجميع على منبر الامم المتحده
ودليلي ان اكثر استراتيجيين الامريكيين
الذين قيموا تلك الخطوه في ذلك الوقت كلهم
اجمعوا على ان ما جرى في سوريا هو
ليس ما جرى في سوريا هو ليس تنسيقا
امريكيا روسيا بل ان الروسي خدع الامريكي
ودخل الى روسيا الى سوريا الى سوريا وبدد
جهد قامت به امريكا في سوريا والشرق
الاوسط لمده 40 عام ا خدع خدع نعم خدعه
لان الروسي لديه اجنده وهو يقوم بصراع مع
الامريكي على الارسيه سوريا هي جزء من جزء
الوسط من اوراسيا اوراسيا بس مشان نوضحها
للناس اوراسيا هي يعني مشروع روسي جديد
يضم اوروبا و واسيا واسيا هذا المشروع
لديه ثلاثه بوابات على روسيا ان تدافع
عننا تكلم عن هذا الم مضوع الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين وتكلم عن هذا الموضوع
الكسندر دوجين الذي هو الراس العقل المدبر
في روسيا في هذا
الاستراتيجيه
ال المستشار السابق للرئيس كارترز بيجن
بريجنسكي تكلم عنها واعتبر ان لهذه
الراسيه الراسين الصراع على اوراسيا ثلاثه
بوابات البوابه الاولى هي اوكرانيا على
امريكا ان تبقى مسيطره على اوكرانيا كي
تدفع روسيا الى الداخل وتمنعها من الوصول
الى المياه الدافئه النقطه الثانيه هي
سوريا علي على امريكا ان اعني بها سوريا
والعراق هذا المحور ان تسيطر لان هذه هي
احد الجسور القاريه في الوسط التي بالصراع
اليو استراتيجي تريد ان تدفع روسيا الى
الداخل وما موقع تركيا في الحلف الاطلسي
الا جزء من هذا السيناريو كي يشكل خرقا في
الاوراسيا النقطه الثالثه والاهميه هي بحر
قزوين وايران كذلك تلك هي البوابه الاخرى
الثالثه البوابه الثالثه البوابه الثالثه
لذا اتى الاجتياح الامريكي الاحتلال
الامريكي لافغانستان كي يقطع هذه المنطقه
في هذه العقده الجيو استراتيجيه والطاقيه
في وسط اسيا من هنا اقول اص بجمله واحده
بس مشان ناخذ النقطه نقطه من هنا اقول ان
سوريا هي جزء من محاور الصراع اتى الصراع
الحقيقي ابدا الصراع الحقيقي بين روسيا
وامريكا على النظام العالم الجديد وعلى
دور روسيا في هذا النظام العالمي الجديد
وبالتالي هناك عناوين نحن نتفق على عناوين
سياسيه انما في
جوهرع ساحق ماحق طيب اخ ايمن يعني نحن
ايضا لماذا نحاول ان نقز هذا الصراع
الكبير يعني الدول الكبرى العظمى لا يمكن
ان تتصرف يعني لافروف وكري لا يمكن ان
يتصرفا على طريقه توم انجري لابد وان هناك
صراعا حقيقيا الان انا عندما اسمع وزير
الخارجيه الالماني بالامس وزير الخارجيه
الالماني مش اي واحد ثاني وهو يقول ان
المواجهه العسكريه بين روسيا وامريكا
اصبحت اصبحت قاب قوسين او ادنى اصبحت
المواجهه خطيره للغايه قال ايضا قال لم
نصل الى مرحله انعدمت فيها الثقه بين
الشرق والغرب كما هي معدومه الان بين
الروس والامريكيين وخاصه على وضع على ضوء
الوضع السوري صحيح يعني هذه المعطيات ايضا
ليست لعب عيال ليست ضحك على الذقون كيف
تنظرون الها يعني يعني انا لا يمكن ان
امشي مع الشارع مثلا يقول لك الشارع 85%
من الشارع حسب التصويتات انه هدول عم
يضحكوا علينا وكذا وكذا بس ايضا في الجوهر
يعني ربما الوضع على عكس ما يراه الشارع
كيف ترد نعم يا سيدي اريد ان اج على
السؤال سؤال حضرتك ثم اعلق على ما قاله
الدكتور من صراع العمالقه يعني انا في
الاصل اجد صراع صغير حتى نقول انه عمالقه
صرع عمالقه المواجهه لماذا سيتواجه داخل
سوريا اذا كانوا الحلفاء للامريكان والروس
هم نفسهم الان ذكرنا قبل قليل لكن اريد ان
اشير الى امر اخر داخل العراق عندما هزم
صدام حسين وانكسر وانكسر و انتهت الدوله
العراقيه نشا ميليشيات من الذي انشا هذه
الميليشيات هذه الميليشيات انشات ب يعني
موافقه امريكيه المليشيات الحشد الشعبي
الحشد الشعبي اللي عم ققول قال المرجعيات
قال عملته اقرار المخابرات الامريكيه يا
سيدي بما يخص الحشد الشعبي تحديدا بس
خلينا خلينا بالموضوع ت بعيد المواجهه اذا
كان هناك الحلفاء هم نفسهم في العراق وفي
سوريا الحلفاء في سوريا يتم تغطيتهم جويا
من الروس وامريكيه في العراق هذه نقطه
النقطه الاخرى دعنا ن س يعني قصدك انه
امريكا تغطي الايرانيين ومليشيات الشيعيه
في العراق اه والروس دقيقه والروس يغطون
المليشيات الشيعيه الايرانيه في سوريا نعم
يعني شو الخلاف اذا وهي وهي نف وهي نفس
الم هناك نقطه اخرى تثبت هذا الكلام ما
قاله ستيف ووكر وهو القنصل الامريكي في
البصره عندما زار جرح الحشد الشعبي في م
مشفى الامام امام الصدر كما يقولون قال
هؤلاء مؤسسه رئاسيه مؤسسه تحت رئاسه
الوزراء وتتبع لولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قال بالحرف الواحد هذا الامر كلام موجود
على النت لذلك عندما يعتبر ان الحشد
الشعبي هو مؤسسه تحت رئاسه الوزراء
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني ان
هؤلاء حلفائهم والحشد الشعبي هو نفسه
مليشيات الفاطميه التي تقاتل ونعم في
سوريا بدعم روسي هناك امر اخر عندما
ذهب السيد فورد الى بسنه 2011 بشهر 4
تحديدا الى احد قاده المعارضه في سوريا في
بيت اب المهاجرين لا اريد ان اذكر اسمه ل
لكن هو يعرف تماما هذا الامر قال له اربع
لاءات اللاء الاولى هي انه لا يجب ان يصل
الاسلاميين للسلطه سارب بين الحديثين
الامر الاخر قال له انه لا يجب طرد
الاقليات من سوريا هذا الكلام كلام فورد
طبعا ليس كلامي الامر الاخر ايضا الذي
قاله لا لتسليح الثوره ولا لاسقاط النظام
في القوه هذه اربع لاءات ماذا قال لافروف
في روسيا لل الذين المعارضين الذين ذهبوا
الى الى روسيا قال نفس الكلام قال لا
للوصول الاسلامي للسلطه بالحرف الواحد
وقال الظام لا وصول السنه ال السنه نعم
انا اريد ان يعني ادعى الامر بانه طائفي
لكن هذه الحقيقه النظام اذا ارد قال
بالحرف الواحد النظام اذا اردتم تغييره
يتغير بانتخابات يعني لا لاسقاط النظام
بالقوه نفسها عند عن فورد يجب الحفاظ على
الاقليات يعني الخطاب الروسي والامريكي في
سوريا نفسه طبق الاصل نعم طبق الاصل وهم
يشتركون في موضوع عدم الوصول الاسلامي
للسلطه وكان الثوره السوريه قامت لقيام وه
البغدادي هذا الامر ان تتصور الثوره
السوريه بهذا الشكل هذا خطا اذا يشتركون
في الاستراتيجيه المستقبليه لرسم شكل
الدوله مستقبلا ويشتركون بالميليشيات التي
تقاتل في سوريا وفي العراق ويشتركون في
حلفاء المنطقه على ماذا سيختلف اما موضوع
الصراع صراع العمالقه يا سيدي كلنا يعرف
ان لولا الامريكان تحديدا سنه
1991 لو لم تقوم امريكا بدعم روسيا لبقيت
الفوضى في روسيا الى الىه هذا اليوم وبيعت
كل اسلحه الاتحاد السوفياتي في الدول
الاسلاميه التي كانت تتبع الاتحاد
السوفياتي هذا يعني روسيا الجديده صنعه
امريكيه نعم صريع هي دوله اقليميه قويه
لكنها ليست دوله يعني لها ثقل عظم نعم اما
موضوع صراع فهو اصغر من كثير من هذه
الكلمه بكثير لا يوجد صراع امريكي روسي
لانه في الحقيقه اذا اردنا ان نتكلم
بطريقه استخباراتيه من الذي اوصل بوتن الى
السلطه تسلمها من يلسن من الذي اوصل يلسن
الى هذه السلطه هي امريكا ومجموعه مخابرات
كانت تدير العالم في ذاك الوقت وكان
اليهود لهم دور في هذا الامر هذا الامر
مثبت ووثائق لدينا وثائق على هذا الامر
يعني لا اتكلم كلام ربما يظنه البعض انني
يعني ابتدعه حتى اثبت وجهه نظري لا هذه
حقيقه يثبتها الجميع وهناك مقالات على
الانترنت تسمي الاسماء بمسمياتها الاشخاص
الذين ساعدوا يلسن الظهور هم سبع اشخاص من
بينهم سته اشخاص يهود هم نفسهم وبينهم
ابنه يلتسن تاتيانا التي ساعدت بوتين
وروجت له في اوساط السياسه الروسيه
وبالتالي هذا كان دعم امريكي حقيقه روسيا
يا سيدي ربما انت تعرف الاقتصاد كثير ربما
يكون هذا
اختصاصك في اوروبا كثير من الدول هناك
تقريبا سته الى سبع دول الدخل القومي يفوق
الدخل القومي الروسي يعني روسيا ليست قوه
بالحجم الكبير الذ كما قال عننا اوباما
قال هي قوه اقليميه ليست قوه اقليميه نعم
اذا يعني لا يجب ان نكبر من حجمها لكن
امريكا تحت تاج الى روسيا حتى تكون فزاعه
في اوروبا لان امريكا تخاف من اوروبا اكثر
م ما تخاف من روسيا روسيا معروف قوتها في
في النووي واول ما هدد فيه الروس هددوا في
الغاء اتفاقيات النوويه التي وقعت لذلك هم
يعرفون الوجع الامريكي اين هم يريدون
روسيا موجوده حتى تسيطر على اوروبا وتظهر
دائما ان فزاعه لكن ايضا يعني اضيف امر
اخير دكتور لو سمحت ما قامت فيه روسيا في
سوريا لن تستطيع امريكا ان تقوم ترف لماذا
لان روسيا تخاف من الحلفاء في المنطقه
هناك حلفاء مثل السعوديه وتركيا هناك
حاضنه شعبيه تؤيد الثوره وتؤيد الشعب
السوري لن تقبل لانه في
الحقيقه لا تستطيع ان تقتتل هذه الدول وا
واول من كسر الاتحد السوفياتي في
افغانستان هم المجاهدون العرب الين ذهبوا
الى
افغانستان شيه انا بدي اخذك من هذه النقطه
دكتور هذا يقودنا الى كلام بان كل الفيتو
حق النقد الذي استخدمته روسيا في مجلس
الامن الدولي ضد المشاريع الامريكيه
المزعومه في مجلس الامن لصالح سوريا كم
فيتو عملت لاثه وه الرابع الرابع اول
امبارح امبارح اول امبارح اخر واحد ماشي
اربعه هناك من يقول ان كل هذه
يعترض وكانك اعطيته هديه مبسوط جدا الزلمه
يضحك وكذا يعني نحن ورا العمليه لانه
امريكا لا تستطيع كما قال لك الدكتور
السيد ايمن لا تستطيع ان تفعل في سوريا
كما تستطيع روسيا يعني كما قال هناك حلفاء
لا تستطيع ان تدخل لصالح النظام بشكل
مباشر فاوعي والسؤال الاخير مشان تبدا انا
بدي اسالك سؤال لماذا لم تتجرا روسيا الا
في التدخل في سوريا لماذا تتدخل في العراق
ولديها اقوى حليف في العراق الا وهو ايران
انت بتعرف الروس والايرانيين اثنين بفرد
الباس بتعرفها اه بالعراق لماذا لم تتجرا
ان ترسل جندي واحد روسيا الى العراق لماذا
لم تتجرا روسيا بارسال جندي واحد الى
ليبيا حيث كان القذافي من اقوى حلفائها
لماذا تدخلت فقط في سوريا تدخلت فقط في
سوريا لانها جاءت بضوء اخضر اسرائيلي اولا
وامريكي ثانيا وما حدا يقول لي صراعات وما
صراعات والله بوتن مثل التوتو بجيبوا
نتنياهو واوباما وما تقول لي وقال لك
بعدين وين القوه الاقتصاديه كلياتهم
بيطلعوا قد اسبانيا اسبانيا اقوى من روسيا
اقتصاديا يا رجل تفضل اولا شكرا لك على
السؤال الاخير اي لماذا لم تتجرا روسيا ان
تتدخل في العراق وفي ليبيا وتدخلت في
سوريا من لانه انا بالحقيقه حابب نخلي
المشاهد العربي يا سلام انا عم انا عم
بطرح لك شو عم بتفكر الناس سلام عل اولا
رد على الاستاذ ايمن حين اتى يلتسن اتى
بعد البريس ترويكا وبعد انقلاب امريكي
يهودي على الاتحاد السوفيتي انا معك وافق
على
التوصيف
لكن بعد الانقلاب التي الذي حدث على
جورباتشوف ومن ثم الانقلاب الذي حدث على
يلتسن المؤسسه العسكريه في روسيا والكبي
حين اعادتهم الى السلطه اعادتهم تحت شرط
انلا يمسوا في الكجب في جيش وفي الاسلحه
النوويه بقيت الاسلحه النوويه والجيش
والمخابرات في روسيا هي تحمل روح الاتحاد
السوفيتي يا سلام عليك بال حين انتهى
يلتسين السكير كلنا ندرك ان الرئيس يلتسين
بكل اسف باع روسيا الى امريكا
وباع الاوليغارش الروسيه كل الاقت الروسي
اتى فلاديمير بوتين بطلب ليس من امريكا
اتى بطلب وضغط من المؤسسه العسكريه
والمخابرات الروسيه وهو رجل تلميذ الكجب
سابقا وحين اتى وضع يلتسن عليه ثلاثه شروط
الشرط الاول ان يبقي التحالف مع الغرب
الشرط الثاني ان لا يمس لان الكيج بي
والجيش ضغطوا على يلتسن بانه انت وضعك
الصحي معش موزون بدنا نجيب غيرك والنقطه
الثانيه ان يمس
بعائله يلتسن ومدخراته الاقتصاديه والنقطه
الثالثه ان لا يغير نظام الليبراليه اللي
اتفق فيه مع امريكا والاتجاه نحو اوروبا
حين وصل فلاديمير بوتين صفى كل الاوليغارش
الروسيه ابقى اليل سنيه اليلت سينيه ابقى
على يلتسن شخصيا وعائلته وعلى مد خراطه
ووضع سال سؤال في في روسيا وكل الكتابات
الروسيه راحت في هذا الاتجاه انت تسرد ما
حدث لكن اسمحلي اسمحلي اسمح لي خليني اوصل
للنقطه الاسيه يلي هي مهمه كثير برز في
روسيا سؤال الهويه من نحن هل نحن غرب او
نحن شرق او نحن من اتت هنا
الراسيه التي هي الجيل المرحله الرابعه من
من من مجد روسيا وهذا بده حلقه قائمه
بذاتها من دون ما نفوت ونخص به الفاص ماشي
كويس جدا اذا اذا باختصار بس المشاهد ف
بوتن ليس سليل يلسن بل هو انقلب على اليل
نقيد هو نقيد وهو رجل كيج بي واعتبر عفوا
اعتبر ان اكبر خطا جيو استراتيجي اصاب
روسيا هي انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وهو
يسعى الى بس جاوبني الان على سؤالي الاخير
انه ليش تدخلت روسيا في سوريا فقط ولم
تتجر على التدخل في العراق مع انه في
العراق ايران صاحبتها صحيح صحيح حين اتى
فلاديمير بوتين سنه ال000 الى الحكم كان
العجز في الميزان التجاري الروسي 300
مليار دولار وروسيا تعيش على المساعدات
الامريكيه باخر عهد يلتسين دفعت امريكا 4
مليار دولار لروسيا كي تستطيع ان تستمر حط
نصب اعين الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين اولا
تقويه المؤسسه العسكريه ثانيا تقويه
الاقتصاد في هذه اللحظه ارتفع اسعار
البترول والنفط الى 100 دولار وارتفع
ارتفاع كبير كانت هذ هي قبله نجاه
الاقتصاد الروسي استطاع ال حين بال 2003
لم تكن روسيا اعادت تجديد ثلاثت العسكريه
ولم تعد انا عم بحكي لك ماشي انا متفق معك
على ذلك الوقت انا عم بحكي لك عن الان
الان لماذا لم تتجرا روسيا على التدخل في
العراق ولا في ليبيا لم تتجر في لان
الامريكان ما بيسمحوا لها انا ساجيب على
السؤال ا لم تتدخل في العراق لان روسيا لم
تكن جاهزه للتدخل في العراق لا عسكريا
الان الان روسيا يا رجل روسيا بوتين يا
سيد دكتور رياض بوتين الان عم فرجينا
عضلاته وعم ققول لك عندي اسلحه وع بيعرض
لنا اس 300 واس 400 ودنيا ليش هالاس 400
وكل هال العضلات الروسيه فقط عم يمارسها
في سوريا على الشعب السوري لانه اسرائيل
وامريكا قالوا له خعم اللي بدك اياه خليني
بس وضح كم صوره اذا بتسمحوا لي لانه من
الاهميه
بمكان هيدي اول صوره يا استاذي تؤكد على
حقيقه الصراع الكوني ايه
اوروبا حين التزمت بالطاقه النظيفه باتت
هي ثاني اكبر سوق عالمي
للغاز منطقه وسط اسيا وبحر قزوين والعراق
وايران هي اول احتياط غازي ونفط في العالم
الصين هي والهند هي اكبر عملاقي اقتصاديين
برزوا في هذه في هذا العصر هذه تؤكد على
ان منطقه مصادر الطاقه ومسارات هي المنطقه
التي يقوم عليها الصراع الا وهي موجوده في
هذه الصوره هي الشرق الاوسط ووسط اسيا اها
اذا العمليه اكبر بكثير من سوريا بالضبط
اتت لذلك اتت امريكا يا سيدي الكريم وهذه
الصوره الثانيه اتت امريكا اتمنى شوف
المشاهد العربي فاحتلت افغانستان كي تقطع
تمدد الطاقه باتجاه الصين والهند واحتلت
العراق كي تمنع تمدد الطاقه باتجاه
المتوسط كي تقضي على سوق اوروبا وتشل
للروسي لان روسيا تعطي اوروبا 40% من
الغاز حلو حلو اذا بتسمح لي بعد نقطه
باختصار باختصار اخر نقطه نقطه نقطتين بعد
اذا سمحت لي
ط مضيق ملقه هذا مضيق ملقه يمر عبر مضيق
ملقه 80 ل 90% من الطاقه
للصين حين مضيق ملقه مسيطر عليه الاسطول
السادس الامريكي والدولتين المتشاطئة
تقيم امريكا معهم اتفاقات هذا يعني ان
الصين ملقوط برقبتها اقتصاديا من
الامريكيين س لذلك الصين اقامت بعد وحده
غير هي اقامت الصين شيء اسمه طريق الحرير
الذي يمتد من الصين الى اوروبا الى الشرق
الاوسط وهذا الطريق يمر بافغانستان ايران
سوريا والعراق والمتوسط من هنا يعني نحن
ممرات نف وغا نعم من هنا وهذه الاخيره من
هنا نرى هذه امدادات الطاقه العالميه اذا
بتشوفوها هذه سوريا هي محور وعقده طرق
غازيه طا قويه للعالم وهي من هنا تاطي
طريق الحرير اذا المعركه على سوريا هي
معركه جيو سياسيه طاقوي س مهمه جدا من
يسيطر على
للروس عفوا عفوا للروس والصينيين الذين
تضيق عليهم امريكا الخناق ط قويا ولامر كي
لا تسمح امريكا لهذه المشاريع ان تستمر س
الك الوقت هذا الكلام في غايه الخطوره في
واقع الامر انه نحن ليس مجرد عناوين بسيطه
التقوا ليش ما راحت على العراق وما راحت
على ليبيا واجت على سوريا القصه انا بدي
اسالك هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان امريكا وهذا
المقال بامكانك ان ترجع له للكاتب
الاسترالي الشهير جون بيلجر كاتب عظيم جون
بلجر يقول لك امريكا لم تترك
ممرا للطاقه باتجاه روسيا وباتجاه الصين
وباتجاه الدول الناشئه الا وسكرته يعني
عاوزه امريكا تخنق الصين وتخنق روسيا
وتخنق كذا طاقوي غازيا نفطيا كذا والصين
وكذا يدركون هذه المشكله حتى روسيا روسيا
يعني لو تسال الروس القياده السياس الشعب
الروسي الحقيقي العادي الشعب الروسي يغلي
ضد امريكا يغلي ضد امريكا اخر مثال عندما
طردوا اللاعبين الروس من الاولمبيات صح
ولا لا عملوا لهم اياها مخدرات و مخدرات
وما بعرف شو طلعوهم روسيا موجوعه جدا هذا
ليس يعني كلام انه والله اصحابه كذا
وبيلعبوا توم انجيري وما بعرف شو هناك
فعلا روسيا موجوعه وتريد ان تنتقم خاصه
فيما يخص طرق الغاز يعني نحن باخر النهار
بسوريا لا فارقه معهم لا بشار الاسد ولا
شعب سوري ولا من يحزنون لعبه مصالح دايسي
و دايسين ابو اللي خلفنا بدهم يمرروا غاز
ونفط وما بعرف شو باخر نار كلنا عم نحارب
يعني فشوش وقود فشوش كيف ت نعم هذا الكلام
يعني انهم متوافقون وليس مختلفون لكن
حقيقه اريد ان اقول كيف مختلفون نعم ه هذه
الصوره تعبر تعبر اكثر من الصوره التي
اظهرها الدكتور خليه شو فرجينا اياها يا
يا مخرج هذه الصوره يعني بيقولوا بالعميه
يا مخرج ك زغر كرب الصوره حط كفك ايه يعني
تصور وزيرين خارجيه اكبر دول ايه نعم حط
طلعي
ايه اكمل نعم هذه الصوره تعبر اكثر عن من
الخرائط التي عرضها الدكتور لانه في
الحقيقه هذه حقيقه الامر وانت سالته قلت
له لماذا لم يعني لم يتعاونوا في بغداد او
لماذا لم يحدث هذا الامر في بغداد لان
بغداد في الاصل هي تقع الان في هذا الحلف
و هذا المحور الان يريدون اسقاط دمشق في
هذا المحور دمشق الثوره وليست دمشق النظام
لانه حقيقه لماذا تدخل الروس تدخلوا كما
قال الدكتور ب 30/9 2015 بس بس مشان اكد
كلامك انا بدي
انقل تغريده لاياد ابو شقره في من تويتر
يقول لك حلب الموصل قاعده ثابته
لروسيا في سوريا واخرى لامريكا في شمال
العراق عصر الاستعمار القديم الجديد بمبه
او بمباركه ولي فقيه ايران يعني متقسمين
تقاسم المنطقه وهذا الامر موجه للدول
الكبيره في المنطقه ال السعوديه وترك ماشي
بس بس بدي اسالك يعني نحن انت تعلم سيد
ايمن قبل سنوات مش امبارح قبل سنتين او
اكثر بدا يظهر اتفاق جديد عالمي اسمه
اتفاق كيري لافروف كاري لافروف وحتى مؤيدي
النظام السوري قالوا في ذلك الوقت بالضبط
قال انه سايكسبيكو الجديد انت بتعرف
سايكسبيكو مش فقط بريطاني مشان المشاهدين
اذا ما بيعرفوا مش
بريطاني مش بريطاني فرنسي بالاصل بالاصل
اه مش سايكسبيكو اللي قسم المنطقه لم يكن
بريطانيا فرنسيا محضا كان بريطانيا فرنسيا
روسيا هو اتفاق سايكس بيكو سازان اوف صح
ولا لا فالان التاريخ يعيد نفسه عن طريق
كيري لافروف فاذا كيري لافروف كما يقول
البعض انا بس بدي اسالك كريي لافروف الان
هم سايكسبيكو
الجديده تقاسم النفوذ في المنطقه خذ الشام
ونحن بناخذ العراق وانت بناخذ كذا يعني عم
يوزعو حصص مثل ما وزعت سايك سبيكو ب
1916 يا
سيدي قال الاستاذ رياض الان ان سوريا هي
قلب المنطقه كل الدول تنظر الى نفسها
بانها قلب العالم يعني قالت هلاري قبل عده
ايام في الفورين بلوسي ان يعني امريكا
تنظر الى نفسها انها قلب العالم على الطرف
الاخر من الاطلس اوروبا وعلى الطرف الاخر
من الهادي الصين بالتالي هي تقول نحن في
منتصف العالم موضوع الطاقه هذا موضوع
تحكمه الاتفاقيات الدوليه وانته نعم وليس
صراعات هذا الامر انتهى منذ الح يعني
برايك لو روسيا س يعني برايك لو سوريا
سيطرت على ممر الغاز في سوريا الامريكان
ممكن يجيبوا ل 1ف جماعه يفجرو لكل ال الان
سوريا لا يمر فيها طريق الكونفو الذي كان
يمر ال الخليج هلق قع هذا الامر هذا الامر
غير صحيح نعم المعابر وال الغاز والنفط هو
في اتفاقيات ب الحرب العالميه الدوليه نعم
لا يمكن ان ينقطع بعز الحرب باي مكان لا
يمكن ان ينقطع هذا الامر ل هنا نعم ليس
صراع طاقه لكن ربما يكون هناك بعض
الاشكاليات نعم تبدل الطرق من جهه الى
اخرى لكن الصراع له علاقه في اسرائيل هذا
هو الاساس وهو الصحيح اسرائيل 50 سنه
النظام السوري لم يطلق طلق على اسرائيل
وكل ما شاهدناه من جنوب في جنوب لبنان من
معارك كانت عباره عن معارك وهميه حتى تزيد
الحاضن لحزب الله وهذه المليشيات وانكشف
حزب الله الان انت بتعرف انكشف حزب الله
بالامس يوم عندما سربت صحيفه واشنطن بوست
كلام كريي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه مع
مجموعه من النشطاء السوريين يوم قالوا له
ليش ما بتقاتل بتساعدنا مشان قاتل حزب
الله وايران قال لهم يا جماعه يا حبوباتي
حزب الله ليس عدونا حزب الله حليف وبعدين
شو قاللهم يعني تصور مش هذا الكلام طلع
واحد من جماعه نبيه بري اللي هو حليف حزب
الله في لبنان شو قال قال كري وامريكا
نسفت حزب الله وكل دعايه حزب الله بجمله
كري كري عم بقول لك يا اخي نحن مش رح
نقاتل حزب الله حزب الله حليفنا حزب الله
دمر في سوريا حقيقه لم يبقى هناك حزب الله
لانه حقيقه قتل منه 1300 مقاتل من النخبه
وعدد المقاتلون الذين قتلوا في في في في
سوريا من حزب الله بالضبط 1380 هذا رقم نف
خل خليني موضوع الصراع اسرائيل قلت لي
اسرائيل نعم اسرائيل يا سيدي اسرائيل
حقيقه لولا هذا النظام الذي حماها على
مدار 40 سنه ماذا تعتقد السوريه الان
عندما ينتهون لماذا يحارب العالم يحارب
السوريين الروس والامريكان لماذا يتفقون
على السوريين لانهم يعرفون تماما ان بعد
انتهاء هذه الثوره سوف يتطلع السوريين الى
فلسطين هذا الكلام انا مسؤول
عنه يمكن ان تبقى هذه الم يمكن ان يحمي
اسرائيل الا هذا النظام الا هذا النظام
لانه في الحقيقه طموح الشعب السوري الذين
يقول دول الممات والممانعه هذه ليست دول
الممانعه الممانع هو الشعب السوري وليس
بشار الاسد بشار الاسد هو ربيب امريكا
وربيب اسرائيل انا ساعطيك امثله ووقائع
وادله على انه ربيب اسرائيل ر امريكا
عندما تسلم القياده من ابيه الذي الذي
توفي س 2000 من الذي قام بترتيب هذا
اللقاء اول برايت اول برايت من الز خارجيه
امريكا نعم هناك ثلاث ساعات هناك اسم مخفي
وانا بعطيك شغله ثانيه هل تعلم مصطفى طلاس
قال اول من عرف بموت حافظ الاسد احزر مين
اول من خبر بتعرف مين خبره اول ما مات
حافظ اسد السي اي اي والسفاره الامريكيه
في دمشق هناك شخص اخر لم يظهر اسمه
الاعلام اسمه خالد قدور هذا الاسم لاول
مره يظهر تعرف من هو خالد قدور خالد قدور
هو ابن ناصر قدور الذي تسلم ضابط امن من
سنه الوحده الى سنت ان تسلم حافظ الاسد ثم
انتقلت نفس المركز الى ابنه خالد قدور
الذي يعتبر حلقه وصل بين الامريكان والروس
والايرانيين هذا الرجل لا يعرفه كثير من
الناس هناك اشخاص يعتبروا دعائم الدوله
السوريه العميقه هذا الشخص منه هو الذي
رتب لقاءه مع ا رايت وقالت اول رايت عندها
هو يعرف ما عليه ان يفعله بالحرف الواحد
ماذا تفس الروس وال يعني باختصار شديد
ماذا تريد ان تقول بخصوص الصراع الروسي
الامريكي نعم الروس الان ينسقون مع
الاسرائيليين في كل شارده و وارده
والقواعد التي في اللاذقيه تنسق مع القوا
خليك شوي خليك شوي انا بدي اسالك دكتور
رياض طيب انا يوم هذا هذه النقطه الاساسيه
انا عندما ارى عندما ارى هذا التنسيق
الروسي الاسرائيلي الكبير في سوريا انت
تعلم نتنياهو خلال تسعه اشهر زار روسيا
اربع مرات انت تعلم العلاقه الطيبه بناتهم
انا عندما ارى انه الروس والاسرائيليين في
سوريا سمنا على عسل والاسرائيليون كما
تعلم موجودون في حميميم في قاعده حميميم
الروسيه لانه اصلا بطلت قاعده بطلت ارض
سوريا وانت تعلم ان كيف اسرائيل قامت
بمناورات عسكريه على شواطئ سوريا بمعرفه
السوريين النظام وروسيا وكذا يعني عندما
ارى الاسرائيليون ينسقون مع الروس من
حميميم من قلب سوريا اه وعندما ارر
الاسرائيليين والروس ينامون في فراش واحد
شو قيمه الصراع مع امريكا انت تعلم عندما
تتفق عندما تقرر اسرائيل امريكا بتصير
تحصيل حاصل الموافقه الامريكيه على الدور
الروسي في سوريا تصبح تحصيل حاصل انت تعلم
من يحدد السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه في
الشرق الاوسط لا اني ولا انت ولا حدا اللي
بددها اسرائيل فعندما ارى انا انه سمن على
عسل الاسرائيلي والروس كيف بتيجي بتقوللي
في صراع امريكي اسرائيلي عفوا صراع امريكي
روسي فيك تقوللي هذه النقطه كيف تقوللي
اولا تبلش من الاخر ليست اسرائيل هي من
تحدد السياسه الامريكيه هلا بطلت كل عمركم
تقولوا كل عمركم تقولوا انتم بتاع
العروبيين والقوميين ان اسرائيل تحدد كل
السياسه الان بطلت ما شاء الله اسرائيل هي
قاعده امريكيه اطلسيه متقدمه في الشرق
الاوسط هي قاعده ام وليست قياده حين اقول
قاعده هذا يعني ان لهذه القاعده قياده
خارجيه طيب يعني حليف حل مش حليفي قاعده
اساسيه مهمه جدا بس ماشي ماشي انا بدي انا
بدي بس بس بس ب بس بدي بس دقيقه بس بدي اج
ل هذه النقطه انا متفق معك اسرائيل لا
تحدد السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه بل هي
قاعده عندما ارى انا هذه القاعده
الامريكيه مثل السمن والعسل مع روسيا اذا
شو اذا امريكا قالت له للقاعده
الاسرائيليه قاعده نفس الامريكيه موجوده
حاليا في الشمال السوري هي قاعده وهي
قاعده تفضل يا سيدي اولا الروس الاسرائيلي
لم يقم مناوره في حميمي في الش المياه
المتوس لم يقم مناوره في
حمامين يا صديقي انا سالت وسالت الروس
وسالت كل فش مناوره ولا في تنسيق م طيب
الاسرائليين يقول لك نحن موجودين في
حميميم حمم صحيح اذا ظر ل الرماد في
العيون يا كانوا الروس قالوا كانوا كذبون
ليش ما كذبون الروس استذ فيصل التنسيق
الروسي الاسرائيلي لان اسرائيل تريد ان
تقيم ترتيبات في المنطقه كلنا يدرك ان
اسرائيل تسير مع المنتصر ترى اسرائيل ان
اوراق اللعبه في الشرق الاوسط تتجه الى
روسيا وحلف المقاومه وبالتالي هي ت لا
لا ابدا ابدا تريد ان تنظر الى الترتيبات
المقبله للمنطقه وما هو دور اسرائيل
وبقائه هي تحاول ان تستدرج او تحاول ان
تستطلع من الروسي ما هي ابعاد خ خليني بس
اجل هذه القطه هذه اجليها بس اذا هذا
الكلام دكتور رياض يعني انت عم تقولنا بما
انه روسيا وحلف الممانعه والمقاومه صاروا
صف واحد وبدهم ينتصروا فاسرائيل رح تنضم
لهم مش رح تنضم مش رح تنضم اسرائيل موجوده
على الخارطه الشرق اوسطيه تركيا موجوده
على الخارطه الشرق اوسطيه السعوديه تتدخل
في سوريا والعراق وهي موجوده على خارطه
سوريا والعراق والشرق الاوسط هذه القوى
الاقليميه التي تلعب بالساحه السوريه
العراقيه حاليا الراعي الاكبر والقوى
الاكبر التي استطاعت ان تقدم الارض هي
روسيا مع هذا الحلف بحكم تواجدها وبحكم
الجيش العربي السوري وبحكم المقاومه اذا
بتسمح لي ماشي المقاومه والحشد الشعبي وكل
الدعم الذي ياتي للجيش السوري ترى روسيا
ان هذا المحور يسير الى ضرب القوى
التكفيريه الوهابيه بالمنطقه وبالتالي
تحجيمها لذلك تسعى اسرائيل الى ان ترتب
اوراقها مع روسيا خليك خليك شويه خلي بس
مشان نوضح التناقض عندك يعني اذا اسرائيل
ضد القوه التكفيريه والوهابيه امبارح
كنتوا تقولوا لنا انه من يرعاهم هم
اسرائيل ليش غيرتوا الان مش كل عمركم
تقولوا لنا انه القوى الوهابيه والتكفير
في سوريا مدعومه من اسرائيل وانه ب اهل
النصره بروحوا بيدوا هلا غيرتوا الوضع غير
غيرت
انت عم تقولني شي استاذ فيصل انا لم
اقوله المشروع الاسرائيلي في سوريا هو
مشروع تقسيمي لكونا طائفيه عرقيه ينس
روسيا عم تسويها وروسيا اللي عم تسويها بس
بس بس دقيقه يا دكتور انا والله بس انا بس
روسيا روسيا ضد تقسيم سوريا طيب امريكا مع
تقسيم سوريا التناقض الامريكي السوري
التركي على موضوع الدوله الكرديه ودخلت
تركيا في هذا الم
لان هناك تناقض على مستقبل
سم انا يوم بسمع بس دقيقه بس دقيقه بس
دكتور بسي هالنقطه هذه وخلص بدي اروح
للاستاذ انا عندما اسمع يعلون وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي السابق قبل ايام في مقال في
اعوت احرنوت يقوللك بالحرف الواحد عفوا
سوري بار يقوللك ايران وحزب الله وروسيا
لا يحلم بدخول سوريا لولا الضوء الاخضر
الاسرائيلي نحن وضعنا شروط التدخل
الايراني وحزب الله وكذا في سوريا هذا
الاسرائيلي وانا والله بصدق الاسرائيلي
اكثر من اي واحد لانه ههم ساده العالم هن
مسكين الروس وهن ماسكين الامريكان وهن
ماسكين الاوروبيين ما نجي نكذب على بعض كل
عمركم بتقولوا لنا ان الصهيونيه تسيطر على
العالم ليش بطلت تسيطر الان اذا اذا
باختصار عندما يقول الاسرائيلي نحن الذين
ادخلنا الروس والايرانيين وحزب الله الى
سوريا وحطينا لهم شروط بتوصل لهون وبس خلي
الطيران الروسي يطلع فوق بعد الليطاني
بلبنان خليه يروح بعد الليطاني خليه شوف
التنسيق بالجنوب في درعا عندما تدخلت
روسيا في سوريا جبهه الموك اللي كانت
اسرائيل بتسيطر عليها سكتت تماما شو يعني
انه تفضلوا يعني يعني لا تستطيع اسرائيل
ان تصطدم بالروسي
ام اولا باختصار باختصار شديد ليس هناك
توافق روسي اسرائيلي على سوريا اطلاقا طيب
المشروع الروسي في المنطقه يتناقض مع
المشروع الاسرائيلي السوري يا سيدي وضعت
انا اربع نقاط اساسيه اريد ان بس دكتور
المشكله الوقت عم بقولي المخرج صار خالص
بس لخصي اياها بس مشان ما نروح بعيد
امريكا ليس لها مصلحه ان تنتصر روسيا في
سوريا لان انتصار روسيا في سوريا هو
انتصار للرئيس الاسد وهذا يعني تمدد
للمحور الروسي في المنطقه بس خليني بس
خليني بس مشان انا ما بدي دخل بس بدي مشان
طيب كيف ترد على الذين يقولون لو كانت
امريكا فعلا ضد المشروع الروسي في سوريا
كان على فقط ان تزود امريكا المعارضه
السوريه ب 50 صاروخ مضاد للطائرات تسقط 10
طائرات روسيه والله سمعت روسيا وهيبه
روسيا راح تروح بزباله طيب ليش امريكا
تمنع تمنع الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات ليش
روسيا ليش امريكا اعطت صواريخ ستنغر
للمجاهدين في افغانستان كي يلعنوا ابو
الاتحاد السوفيتي ويسقطوا ولماذا تمنعه عن
المقاتلين السوريين لانها تريد روسيا ان
تفعل ما تريد امريكا ليس صحيحا لان لان رو
لان امريكا تخاف في هذا التوقيت وفي هذا
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها امريكا ان
تتدحرج الحرب في سوريا الى مواجهه روسيه
امريكيه ستؤدي الى زعزعه المنطقه
وتاثير على اسرائيل جميل جدا انا بدي
اسالك سؤالين متناقضين شوي انا بعرف اول
شيء انت تعلم وهذا السؤال كان لازم الوجه
للدكتور رياض سامي كليب احد اهم كتاب
الممانعه والمقاومه نشر مقالا مهما عنوان
يهوديه بوتين هل تنفع العرب وسوريا قال
فيه لم يقدم اي رئيس سوفيتي او روسي ليهود
روسيا ما قدمه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين لم
يقدم رئيس روسي على مدى تاريخ روسيا
لاسرائيل ما قدمه بوتين باختصار يقول انه
يا جماعه اسرائيل وروسيا على قلب رجل واحد
في سوريا وفي المنطقه وبوتين يموت بدباديب
بيموت بدباديب الاسرائيليين والاسرائيليين
بدهم يعملوا تماثيل لبوتين في كذا اذا
العمليه يعني ما ممكن نصدق انه في صراع
امريكي اذا كان الاسرائيل والروس بس بنفس
الوقت انا بدي اسالك طيب لماذا نصبت روسيا
صواريخ اس 300 من يومين واس 400 مضاده
للطائرات وعندما قال لافروف نحن سنحمي
اصولنا و بروتكت اور اسس ان سيريا اه طيب
هذه الصواريخ الاس 300 و400 الروسيه لمين
معموله مين لضد الامريكان نعم ساقول لك
لماذا نشرت هذه الصواريخ نشرت هذه
الصواريخ عندما تقوم تركيه والسعوديه
وتقول انه يجب اسقاط الاسد بالقوه تقوم
هذه الدول بجلب هذه الصواريخ رساله الى
اوروبا الصواريخ التي تخيف اوروبا ذهبت
الى سوريا ابتعدت عن اوروبا وعندما تتراجع
اوروبا وتقول انه يجب تغيير نظام بشار
الاسد وذهاب بشار الاسد تقوم ايضا روسيا
بعمل عمل معاكس بنشر اسلحه وصواريخ على
حدود نعم على حدود اوروبا هذه رسائل روسيا
لا تحتاج الى صواريخ اس 400 اصلا في الاصر
هي نشرت اس 400 لماذا تنشر اس 300
المتطوره اكثر هي رساله عندما تندفع تركيا
والسعوديه الى الامام اكثر في موضوع
المطالبه بذهاب بشار الاسد والتسليح تقوم
بزج عدد كبير من الصواريخ وانواع جديده من
الاسلحه وعندما تتراجع بمباركه امباركه
امريكيه نعم يا سيدي انت برايك نعم اريد
اقول كلمه اخيره هل برايك الطيرات التي
تطير في الجو النظام السوري والروسي
والامريكي والاسرائيلي هل هي باصات هوب
هوب هي طائرات تحتاج الى غرف عمليات
توجهها بنفس الوقت اذا هناك غرفه عمليات
تنسق
الطيران لدي معلومه من داخل سوريا نعم
هناك من يتحدث عن ان هناك تنسيقا بين
طائرات الاسد والطائرات الامريكيه
الامريكان يقولون للاسد معك ع ساعات لدك
حلب اقصف حلب وبعدين نحن بنطلع من دك مناط
هذا ما اتحدث عنه يجب ان يكون هناك غرفه
عمليات من الناحيه العسكريه تقود العمل
الجوي بنفس الساعه لكن هناك امر اخير بس
انته انتهى الوقت يعني باختصار تريد ان
تقول عندما نرى الطائرات الاسرائيليه
والامريكيه والروسيه والسوريه يطيرون في
نفس ال هناك تنسيق 100% لكن كلمه وس هناك
صراع امريكي ما ضرب في الجنوب ضربته
اسرائيل هي مناطق كان يمكن ان يستوي عليها
الثوار فقامت بضربها اسرائيل حتى لا تصل
الى ذ الثوار خدمه للنظام ايضا لانه حقيقه
يعني باختصار شديد الكل بفرد الباس وانت
بتعرف بالسوري يوم بقول بفرد الباس مش هيك
اثنين بفرد الباس ن نعم مشاهدينا الكرام
لم يبقى لنا ان نشكر ضيفين السيد ايمن
العاسمي والدكتور رياض عيد نلتقي مساء
الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين ا فيصل
القاسم يحييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء
يعطيكم العافيه اهلا فيك
[موسيقى]
دكتور